okay okay work back
we finished round five yesterday and
today is a rest day so we can relax just
over halfway through the tournament and
chess is really tiring
he feeling like one game at a date it
takes a lot of energy out of you but I
think we're both doing well so far
yeah I'm tied for first place four and a
half out of five next round is tomorrow
I'm on board one playing the top seed so
hopefully I can continue the non losing
streak yeah you'll be playing the one of
the two GM's they're here yeah so will
be it'll be a tough fight that's right
and it's unfortunate that if there's not
three GMS so there's no possibility of a
GM one right but can't ask for that much
yeah so I guess we can start with my
game from yesterday it was another
London game and like every time I play
the London I'm super paranoid that my
opponents will be preparing for me but
you gotta get my opponent started
thinking after move one which was nice
so going into this round you were on
three and half out of four right yes I
had just drawn you the previous day so I
had another white and the third time
playing the London this tournament and
yeah I I was actually expecting my
opponent to play you six on move one but
okay he played a bit differently c5 and
when he was taking his time in the
opening and then especially after my
next move in this position he took a
decent amount of time and then
mishandled the position this is actually
one of the lines which inspired me to
play the London this move here at Knight
to c3 which well you don't see too often
in London where usually your your plan
was to go to c3
I remember discovering this like a few
years ago just like having stockfish
running in the background and Knight c3
if I'm not mistaken as the top stockfish
move
and it's pretty rare like most players
will play c3 I think there is some
Nakamura cop ski games they went into
like these main lines with c3 but nice
t3 is really interesting because there's
really two ideas my idea is to play pawn
to d5 and another potential idea is
something like b5 right and there's a
pretty venomous trap in this position
I've had a lot of bullet games online
where black plays d5 and then Knight d5
just wins on the spot I actually had
this over the board once against Ashman
gyro whoops is also a London player but
he wasn't familiar this is not about it
it was just start like a casual books
game but but still I mean it's useful to
know so already like Black has some some
issues to solve and I think a lot of
players don't find the right response
here that shouldn't take and then after
take bishop before is the best line for
black and it's still playable for white
like Bishop III Castle and it's a game I
would not have minded this if if we went
down this path but I think he played
just a dubious move here you played a6
allowing d5 which I think just gives
white a really nice position
d5 take take and now I have control over
the d5 square ready to play Bishop c4 I
was actually surprised like how much I
got from early on given that just had
like this one Square controlled but
after a d6 I just continued development
Bishop to c4 and the nice thing is that
he can't really play b5 because I take
on that six and played Bishop d5 so he
had to do something a bit different
he played Knight takes d5 Bishop take T
5 and then Bishop e7 Singh is just
trying to complete development and at
this point I was actually I was really
happy with my next move
and after I played my next move he took
about half hour maybe a bit more than
half hour Wow
and I just then got a huge time
advantage I think this is a good kind of
positional exercise or more strategical
exercise which you don't usually see in
tactics trainer like the the move I play
here isn't a tactic it's just a very
strong idea and facilitates some
potential attack is it just castles
that's where that was gonna finish I
don't think he would even think for half
hour the idea for white is to try and
clamp down on black and prevent black
from completing developments like it's
clearly here he wants the castle develop
LightSquared bishop and just try and get
some playable middlegame position so I
played that I played a move here which I
thought it's it's a move that you often
see in bullets or you just kind of play
hoping it works but I thought like even
in a classical game this move is very
strong the move is pawn h4 looks a bit
random at first but the simple idea I
just won't play that g5 and there's some
nice lines like if you were to Castle
here I would play Knight g5 and all the
sunders threats so the of Queen age
factor which is devastating and there's
a nice line if if h6 I'm pretty sure I
haven't checked this with the engine but
I'm pretty sure Queen d3 is just winning
how does he defend me he can't play g6
because queen take g6 and if he takes
the knight but ok chest AC is but if he
takes with pawn I take back an h-file
opens yeah you can't really stop me I'm
in 87 pretty serious I'm guessing you'd
have to take on g5 with the bishop but
then I take back the pawn and yeah this
[ __ ] life would be good Queen g6
Petzval still happening yeah so I had
seen this when I played h4 and realize
there's so much potential with targeting
both h7 and f7 and bringing the Queen
and so right
yeah so he I don't think he can castle
hit everybody isn't like before right
and that line after Bishop e5 so so
point III and then Bishop take g5 yeah
tick like before yeah maybe this is
possible
can i play Queen Queen g6 is too slow
yeah still feel like white should
maintain some advantage here maybe Queen
b3 just because I'm ready to castle and
continue counsel Queen side and continue
attacking on the King side
maybe he got some initiative like take
take Bishop u6 yeah yes let's give pawns
and just get his pieces out if he's
gonna survive yeah I mean this this
combination of work on each one and plan
on g5 should be yeah very strong yeah
boo clearly Cal says this way too
dangerous for black yeah so that's why
he was taking so long
like what to do for a black he like I
still want to play Knight g5 as well and
just target off sudden a move like
Bishop e6 doesn't really help because I
can probably just take and then Knight
g5 so I was expecting Bishop g4 here
after which I would just play like c3 in
Queen c2 I thought that and his bishop
could be a target later on so he he
surprised him with his next move here I
I took some time after he played his
next move Queen c7 because it just
seemed pointless and he just seemed to
be asking for Nick g5 I really didn't
see the purpose of very slow yeah I
thought maybe for a moment that he had
some idea of playing 98 which shouldn't
happen the game but okay I go for Knight
g5 yeah I think already likes advantage
is very big and actually I realized if
he plays 98 defending f7 I can target or
start targeting d6 I can play 94 here
it's another advantage tonight g5
there's just all these potential targets
in the position yeah
so he played Bishop take g5 which is
kind of a sad move giving up the bishop
hair allowed each file to open
and I thought around here I would win
the game pretty quickly but it took like
two more hours to win this win the
position from here but I think I was in
control the whole time 95
I give up the bishop hair just to get a
lot of intuition yeah that's a real
interesting decision um well I just saw
that I put my queen on a three and black
has no moves here my black has like
almost nothing to do like his Bishop
stuck
he can't Castle yeah this is so this is
the famous but Vinick Bishop have you
seen any of those games where in the
name zone you dislike plants a different
one d5 I have not terraces well sure
maybe we can I will include a link in
the sounds good in their comments or
something just like chess games right
there a couple famous games he just
plays like c-44 and the bishop is just a
rock mm-hmm and like out plays Knight up
plays likes prohibition yeah this seems
like a classic example any of the h-file
right I mean it's like he's like there's
all all these things that he's tied down
to like the be silent song about
southern colonies southern pawn and he
has no way to really fix anything so I
was feeling really good around here but
he put up resistance I think he did what
he kind of had to do is play Bishop e6
and make some concession and then I took
a long time here debating do I take on
b7 or do I take on e6 I'm not sure if I
made the right decision well as taking
on e6 looks really attractive that would
be my choice here and then get hustles
so I so I spent a long time calculating
like these concrete variations trying to
find like a clear win because I wanted
to castle and just seems amazing for a
white like it looks on the half-open
file an open file pawn structure for
black is terrible
but I didn't see like a clear cut maybe
I was looking for too much but I didn't
see anything clear-cut after room
I calculated take King take his cleanest
title out to be seven so he has to take
the king then queen bee for where I'm
likely winning age seven
I actually I was about to go into this
so I saw this nice shot that he plays g6
I can just take on g6 and then I take on
any shade we McQueen back but I thought
that's what was I thinking well I
thought he could play King c8 here and
then if I take on h7 take take
let's move Queen a if I would be
annoying having made in one threatening
the a pawn I'm probably still win I
probably just have c3 and take on g7 for
winning you can take the G sound Paula
Chuck and then yeah maybe I should have
gone for this I just saw Queen 85 and it
looks scary and the other line I was
just winning a pawn and maybe it was
there something else maybe there's
nothing else black can do here to defend
his Queen a5 I just take on b7 yeah I
probably should've onto this well there
is there's H sex but it's just like
making more weaknesses
IH 6 H 5 that he can take with the
Brooke maybe this is what I didn't want
to have happen it's taking a fake Queen
h4 check I'll in the pawn yeah I was
scared of some Queen ending where it his
Queen gets active growing a a5 but I
probably could have brought into this
and had no issues yeah yeah this feels
technical just cuz these positions are
so hard to defend also and right these
weaknesses
I mean Bishop take b7 just seems a lot
more simple the only good I went upon
and the positional aspects like his pawn
structure is ruined on the Queen side I
still have a pawn in g5 his rook is
stuck to the offending h7 but it took a
lot of effort to win I don't think I'll
give as much commentary in terms of
converting this position we trade Queens
we're not some some moments but it was
just a matter of technique castle he
played rook before which is an
interesting move he wanted to get
Congress a maybe preparing both c4 and
a4 and he also had some threat of a
Butchie for just resourceful cuz my G
pawns or as a weakness so I was happy
with the move I played here at one c4
sometimes strange to pawpaws online
squares with widespread bishops but I
had a cute idea of playing Bishop to b5
and then it's just dropping the rook
with king c2 in 83 yeah
so you had to move back and then I just
put the bishop on b5 so I'm limiting any
Queen side play I think going forward
here
slowly but surely bish 57 I thought was
nice and then just a matter of improving
that the rook on each 645 start
targeting some pawns and then well I
should note so after after he had played
Queen c7 I was up an hour on the clock I
had like an hour and 20 minutes to 20
minutes oh that's huge so at this point
he was already below a minutes it's only
moved 26 and I realized that if I just
play a waiting move here it's really
hard to find it and move for luck
because like his pieces are all just
kind of stuck so I just played f3 yes
and he had like 45 seconds to play his
next move it was just so difficult for
back he might be in some I want to call
this is long and but like okay the the
bishop is pinned his rook on the eights
I mean doesn't want to move because then
I can take on c5 so yes I probably just
make some concession here
you played King g7 which allowed just
some simplification Bishop f5 and then
we trade off a bunch of things trade
bishops I'm still up a pawn like a look
at his pawn structure it's just can you
fix it with E 4 and then I fix
everything that he for my plunging Tsar
nice they still got some counter play
like he went for only
he had as chief or me yeah that's an
attempt I play brocade seven Chuck kingi
six and then when I originally played
rook age seven my plan was to play work
g7 here which i think is also just a
nice nice way to win because after take
take he's in some sort of looks long
like the G plan is gonna be lost since
King has no moves and then the idea
would be to win a pawn in the end so
this is one way to win something very
similar happened
I play work a seven similar ideas I have
this structure so good and Rickon games
like efore d5 against d5 right as well I
can never defend this pawn if you just
attack it you give a check you put your
riff on e6 and exactly there's no the d5
is always a long-term weakness yeah I
played rook a seven because I was uh I
was seeing the sign if he takes site I
can just trade off Brooks into a King
pawn ending and this is just waiting for
White's past pasty fun so he played work
out for avoiding the rook trade and okay
we trade some pawns and I finally get
this rookie six moves so I wouldn't a
pawn and then he he went for counter
play and he actually he he made me think
I thought this was gonna be an easy win
but he found some interesting resource
plan c4
looking back on it I had everything
under control but during the game it was
a little bit scary because idea is after
I take he plays King d6 and he's
attacking my rook and he just wants to
bring his King to to c3
yeah and just make me go for some eating
attack down three pawns in a rook ending
so I had to be a little bit careful
I played rookie six and the next several
moves were just calculated
realized that I can just start pushing
pause yeah but is okay there I guess
there's a trap here that if I play d7
I'm pretty sure this is a draw because
King c3 I'm almost getting needed by
force I would have to move the eight
like a four and then after check King a
to check I don't think I can avoid the
repetition because he has rookie one
here yeah this place yeah so when I saw
this like this is one of the first times
I saw I was I was pretty scared oh how
did I get out of this thankfully okay I
don't have to play d7 there might be a
few different ways to win this but
simplest I found was king c1 had just
run towards the center and after a king
c3 King do you one he takes on a two and
now my pawns are too fast but I can't
play d7 because rook T to check so I
pushed my C Ponte nice and then a four
and I just win the race c7 he resigned
here I was expecting him to play on King
g3 threatening mates and then I would
just queen yeah I guess Queen C wants um
so yeah I think it was a smooth game
another success with the London which
has worked well for me in this
tournament I don't know how many games
I'm gonna get to continue playing the
London now that they're being broadcast
on chest 24 and probably more more of my
future opponents will realize that but
they'll fear it yeah maybe they're
afraid it's hard to prevent the London
though surrender yeah we'll see what
happens okay so also I saw some youtube
comment that someone is asking for like
the PGN of the games at least of my like
one of my other games and I I don't know
where I'm gonna like share the PG ends
with people I I do want to do that but
for now you can just view them on the
broadcast chest 24 which will include
links to in the description and then if
if people want to view your games they
can check out the patreon page Oh much
deeper analysis than me yeah what I was
what I've done for all my recent
tournaments is well people watch the
videos already know this but I've
imitated my games and I put them up on
my patreon page where people can follow
and also learn about
like just improvement in training and
stuff like that well my game yesterday
was pretty crazy
the opening was actually really
interesting I know people are wanting to
hear about it um a very trendy line yeah
so I'm playing a 2300 player feed a
master Victor vas es su who's a Romanian
player and looking at his games in the
database he didn't have a whole lot of
memes in this position but I did know
that he's playing the open Sicilian very
consistently and he's typically going
for sharp lines like Bishop g5 against
Knight ARF against the time honest
Sicilian which was my my main line he's
from what I saw has only played the move
f4 which is a decent move it's
definitely not the most critical test
but because the day the round was at I
think 4 p.m. right you know we had like
the whole day to prepare and Eric and I
were joking that he has the whole day to
prepare so he's pulling in a prepare
something super sharp in particular
maybe the line with Bishop e3 a6 and
Queen f3 which is just currently all the
rage and the time on it these days I
mean if there's ever been a serious
existential threat to the time on of
it's a sign disposition so many games I
mean high-level battles to see Caruana
and kraken and VL and anon they're all
playing these lines but i I mean if I
were to expect this no before this game
I was joking that and I'm gonna stop
playing the time on it because of this
land I had so many bad experiences with
this alright yeah I mean it's very
dangerous I think I have one win and one
loss but the difference in strength was
pretty this is like a new sort of
opening like though only the last three
years right yeah it's just dominated at
least time on theory yeah and this
usually doesn't happen just like a line
just kind of takes over it just comes
out of nowhere basically for the first
time I ran into this was against Fidel
Corrales
and it was like 2015 2014 I was like one
of I think like he played it maybe a few
months after who was first played in
like the master level play I thought
nothing of it but then it just became so
popular it picks up steam very quickly
now the ironic thing is that like
White's whole idea you know we're
talking about how sharp the line is is
just to get a slightly better in game
after Knight f6 Queen g3 not challenging
our queen and you know after Queen takes
g3 hg3 gets the open H file slightly
better position can always go for these
plans with like g4 g5 and bother the
night I don't mean like I think the end
game is very playable I don't think
black is really all that much worse here
but it is unpleasant
I've suffered many times I played buzzy
so in the sign online okay and like the
fact that white has the half-open H file
and the half-open D file there's almost
two long-term strategies for light and
it's difficult against a strong opponent
- me but um well for this reason you
know black takes great pains to avoid
the same game and that means just going
into a lot of these sharp complications
okay but yeah I wasn't 100% expecting
this because I mean there was no reason
to expect that other than he has all day
to prepare so he might go for something
super sharp and judging from the games
that I saw he's a very very sharp player
always attacking sacrificing um he's
upset I think a lot of strong players
just because he's you know attacking
player by nature they said yeah I mean I
was even thinking before the game to
play a different move on move on like e4
e5 just to avoid you know all this crowd
but then I thought you know I should set
a good example for my students like if
one of your students doesn't play their
main line because there's like a true
don't be afraid yeah yeah so I was like
okay you know what I'm not gonna back
down from a fight I mean it's not like
I'm playing MBL or someone so I'm over
95 + b5 this is one of the the trend
airlines nowadays like there's a lot of
other off
I mean you could simply play d6 I think
this line that if anyone wants to know
what to do and you don't need a lot of
prep just play d6 Castle Bishop d7 and
play kind of typical Scheveningen style
with Rick cat5 Bishop e7 Knight f6
simple not yeah the one idea you kind of
need to know here for black is when
white plays Queen g3 and puts the pawn
on g7 is that you can sacrifice the g7
pawn it many lines um usually like
Knight of 6 would be played something
like there should be 2 and then let's
say rook c8 white plays f4 and after f4
a lot of times black wants to play h5
mm-hmm so you can help fight for the g4
square and then now you're ready to play
Bishop e7 because Queen takes always
runs into Rick Jay now this is very
romantic yes I think I think this
position is very very playable and you
don't need like this crazy computer crap
you can rely on your intuition here but
I wouldn't with this line I think it's
pretty sharp and here he went into a
thing
Oh so to clear Clara if he does end up
playing this line in the game and in the
game when you play Bishop e3 I think he
like he like fumbled a little bit like
his hands were shaking oh really and to
me that's a pretty obvious tell it's
like the first time they've played the
position or like one of the first times
because they're not used to just making
this move but yeah he started thinking
here and the reason he got confused is
because typically black starts with
Knight of 6 in this position then after
white castles black can play b5 and he
was he was trying to figure out why I
played b5 first if he just castles here
we basically transpose into this line
there's a lot of theory after f4 94 and
h5 and these lines get really really
messy one of the thematic ideas that a5
is typically medic I just want us yeah
this is the one of the few lines I've
studied including
three all right v4 is a really nice
counter-attack yeah I mean if you're
allowing the e5 pawn without your
opponent d6 and you have to watch out
for this your score always but he thinks
a little bit here and then he plays f4
which is definitely a logical move or
probably not not the most challenging um
and then after the game he he did tell
me that he had prepared this the whole
morning hours and hours and he just
didn't check this line with with b5
basically okay f4 hits the night I think
night c4 is kind of forced I have to go
forward and he takes Queen takes and
castles so already just like super
double-edged position I saw in this
position and I thought like black is
just terrible there is completed with
development you have nothing develop the
great Queen you do have the bishop pair
there though it's still well you know I
I used to like be of the same opinion if
I would see this kind of position but
then studying a lot of these lines from
White's point of view where you get this
huge development advantage but black
just has this weird counterfeit before
and Bishop d7 and so during the game I
realized like well if he doesn't make
any threats then he has a real problem
with the e4 square that's true um and
yeah concretely white just doesn't have
anything now we know about the light
squared bishop is hard to blow things
open that can be frustrating for a white
when you're like fully developed but
it's like a temporary advantage right
and you can't make use of the temporary
advantage think he was saying that after
the game yeah yes just frustrated yeah
well yeah that's the problem the the
initiative kind of fades out yeah it's
black two-player so I could play b4
right away and just take the a2 pond but
this line is like way too sharp and
looks risky I just thought like okay I'm
really just only playing with my queen
like
because the the attack is not dangerous
unless I have like more pieces involved
so I wasn't sure yeah in 96 is a big
idea Bishop e7 I think this is a better
move and yeah there's just nothing I can
do the problem is the queen is just very
annoying it's hard to disrupt it can't
play b3 now I am threatening b4 I'm just
taking on e4 or just playing Knight f6
if Y plays a move like a 5 then I'm in
time to play 97 and when I can come to
d5 and or c6 it's nicely developed and I
think his Queen here just ends up I mean
not misplace but it's a little off size
because it's sitting g7 but he sounds
defend it so what to do um he played
Knight b3 I think this is very logical
would have tried it 95 I was a Knight of
6 and now if Knight a5 my idea is to
just take on e4 and the tactics here
work out for black he takes on c4 I take
on g3 and then the rook will be hanging
if he takes on e4 and can take with the
Queen
he can take them to b7 Queen takes b7
and he definitely has compensation here
for the pawn because I'm underdeveloped
but I think it can be hard for white to
really prove this because your king is
safe for the time being yeah I would
take back here yeah it's very solid it's
like white house - well there's no clear
way for white to win the pawn back what
just hasn't developed this pieces
normally and hope that black can't can't
improve his position here so definitely
good positional compensation but King
black is fine he didn't want to go for
that he played rugby for forcing me to
back up
b5 95 Knight takes d5 Bishop takes d5 so
this point I was feeling extremely
comfortable because my light square
bishop is very very powerful
I can play g6 at any moment to defend
the pawn and then develop my bishop and
my King will be safe and I have this
plan to play a5 a4 in every position
that's extremely annoying so he takes a
very practical decision here and just
plays rook takes d5
and I definitely felt like this this
might be kind of the critical move in
the position but I was surprised by how
quickly he played it just like
effortlessly realized he has to do this
this sometimes it's a playful move you
don't necessarily calculate you just
have a feeling that yeah the
compensation should prove itself yeah
and he's definitely getting rid of my
best piece right and weakening my
structure so he's getting a lot of these
strategic advantages yeah so this this
was a tough position to play okay I
answer to Rick CA just to threaten
meeting one queen f2 and here I decided
to hold on to the pole can be salmon
which now I realized is probably too
greedy what I should have done is just
develop the bishop give them one point
for the exchange and then just castle
yeah and I think White has some
compensation still for sure but it's
only one pawn if blacks works to get
active if black is able to play d6 and
open some files then clearly only black
will be better and yeah I think this is
probably the way to go that's great when
you're up the exchange and you have like
at least one open file like even the
fact that you have the C file you can
potentially triple up and go for like B
for breaks right this looks very fine
for black yeah
and White's pieces are good but they
don't have a lot of targets I think the
main idea for ye would be to try to play
like f5 nice accents in many of these
cases exactly black can play off six and
everything is very solid and so this e
six pawn it rarely feels dangerous just
a decoration probably just a weakness -
yeah exactly Queen C six Queen C four as
possible over key a and I think whitus
having a hard time holding on to
everything so yeah that was that was
definitely the way to go but okay I play
Queen b7 and my idea was to try and
learn him to play Knight a5 because it
looks so tempting pushing my queen back
but then
to have a temple with bishop before and
I get to castle so this would be very
worth it
of course he doesn't he doesn't play
that he just plays f5 which i think is
the best move and then i was trying to
figure out what to do in this position
only here i realized that actually my
bishop has no squares like bishop before
you can just play a3 and I have to go
back and if I put my Bishop on e7 at any
point he just plays f6 with tempo and
now this feels way too weakening for
black like I was considering for a brief
moment to just plain his ship f8 here
the idea that if he takes I've taken
castle it just looks wrong though yeah I
mean I I really couldn't bring myself to
play this like 94/95 potential yeah
first of all this a second well even if
he does take and then I take he can do
that and hit my bishop so not giving me
the chance to play g6 mm-hmm it's not an
f5 I mean it's just so strong it it's
hard to knife f5 yeah Queen g3 I mean
this pieces are placed perfectly I even
considered the g6 here which I thought
was interesting just to force them to to
commit the pawn and if f6 on the
position closes up but I thought this
one would be really annoying work f1
mm-hmm so not taking and allowing me to
play rook h7 but starting with this move
and I just couldn't find them good good
move here for black so yeah then I then
I realized my positions actually kind of
drastic and I need to do something quite
um so I don't think he realized and the
others soon enough like you played Queen
d7 right not realizing the difficulty or
really just give back the pawn in Castle
yeah sorry like exactly how I wish I
could go back to this moment I just
played Bishop e7 because once I got here
are already I'm thinking do I just play
d4 and try to you know mess with this
coordination what's the new no I think
you were too materialistic yeah he's got
punished for its well but here I
remembered a recent game I had against
GM Varga where I sacrificed the exchange
with white
and then analyzing that game i similarly
had an that on b3 i had a lot of good
squares he missed one chance to create
counter play and that was just to play a
5a for harassing my knight and creating
this song by shaving out of Bishop on b3
but basically creating this counter play
so I thought of that game and then I
realized like oh I can't play five here
if he takes I get the open a file in
otherwise I'm just getting this counter
play with 84 right
and so I realize this is probably my my
only move in the position least from a
practical point of view I think the
computer agrees actually says that's
quite happy I went for this okay now if
he doesn't take the pawn I'm gonna play
a four a three and make a lot of
weaknesses so he finds the best he takes
a queen a eight and Queen d2 which is a
really strong move because he's
defending the knight of course he's not
allowing Knight be three Queen takes a
two or I'm also turning Queen b3 next
move so white is just in big trouble
but Queen d2 holds everything and he's
starting to take on d5 the idea that I
don't have time to take on e5 because he
takes on 87 so I went for my only move
here Bishop c5 but he missed a really
nice tactic here so for the record I
would say Queen a8 is actually a mistake
here but I should have played Queen a6
avoiding the the tactic that could have
happened in the game and here we get
kind of we got an unclear position but I
think block is more or less okay here
because I've gone in a castle I have
these open files
it looks like enough counter play the
problem here is that after Queen d2
I played what I thought was the only
move Bishop c5 just to develop take take
and so the critical move here was
definitely Queen before to which I
pretty much have to respond Queen c8 and
then my idea is that if white spends a
temple defending the pawn like c3 of
rook d2i castle and I'm okay right but
one was a very very strong move here if
you guys want to try and find it you can
pause the video
I know you can see the notation but III
haven't looked yet
oh no I thought I saw a potential move
I'm so fixated on the smooth I have not
checked the notation very good 97 97
I did not sheets nice fantastic move so
we both missed this although I don't
know if my opponent considered cleaning
before or not being so scared of rooks
he too was just King V wine and right 96
is coming now in other lines you know I
could take on G 2 here and I get Queen
c2 as a threat but okay I'm just not in
time here many sixes his game over ah
black can't castle that's like this a
key yeah the idea that's the whole point
of pinning the Queen before is that I
can't get out so after Knight b7 takes I
mean black who's just lost essentially I
think I have to take the knight give
back the exchange but I still can't
Castle and so this is just horrific
position I have a question what if so
the back after yeah after King be one
Queen see 696 I soon there's also f6
yeah your king is so sad just be like
but 96 did you want to just ride just
wanted to play King f8 hmm and allowing
me discovery and then King g8 but f6 is
strong but there is takes in over 94
else we have Queen c5 so it's not not so
bad but yeah I think just f6 ok so yeah
this would have been this sort of in
this winning clearly winning but he
fortunately did not find that he plays
b4 it was just a very ambitious move
he's securing the night and he's kicking
the rook out and he's winning the d5
pawn by 4 so Trixie 7 Queen takes d5 and
here I feel like I mean another good but
somewhat difficult decision my original
idea was to play queen c8 rib d2 and
castles
but the problem is is that if you can
just take the b5 pawn and I don't get
enough counterplay I mean it's just
gonna be terrible no it has a lot more
material where I can just come back to
b3 + c5 he pushes the a pawn and you
just in complete control so I realized
that I just can't give up the b5 point
unless I'm really activating all my
pieces so somewhat begrudging way I
counselled which turns out to be the
best move but you know it's unfortunate
because that allows white to trade
Queens and get this endgame that's I
think only white is playing for the win
here yeah material-wise is now equally
as nine and two pawns for the rook but
as king is really helpful on the Queen
side his work is active my king is out
of the game my works have one target on
the C file but it's easily covered so
and your b5 and d7 pawns are fixed and
rook you can put the rook on d5 it just
seems good for whites yeah everything
here is in in White's favor but
concretely black does have some some
resources for counter play okay he plays
king b2 over k c8
now I was expecting rigsy to you know as
any natural player would make but I was
okay with this position because I feel
like it's hard for him to make immediate
progress for example if I play move like
King f8 if he tries Knight b3 I can go
in with my rook let's say Rick c4 and
rookie for something like this start
getting counter play
but the problem is well he hasn't play
rugby - he plays c4 everything is a
fantastic move and I go I don't want to
say overlook this during the game but it
is one of those nodes where again like
okay if he plays it he plays it I'll
figure it out then otherwise you know
what choice do I have
I gotta put my rooks on this NFL and
it's a very very strong move because he
he shuts down all of my counter play he
blockades with his King and clearly he's
gonna get too connected past
that are gonna be really really strong
yeah that's a nice size yeah I think
it's yeah it's a nice idea okay now I
realize I just have to get counterplay
immediately so I play Ricki gate he
takes on c4 which I thought was
interesting
my point is that if he plays any kind of
rook d5 trying to keep control you know
I'm just playing f6 and the problem is
my rook is gonna be able to get in I
don't care about the king side here at
all because my king has it under control
and then here I feel like black now has
serious counter played the C pawn is
running Brigades you checked and this
would be very unclear I think the engine
points out that b5 was playable but it's
kind of hard to advance before you know
you're ready to support these pots so he
didn't want to go for this he took on c4
now black is a lot of options so again I
definitely considered f6 but as it turns
out he six is very strong here and he's
able to just kind of shut me down for
example it can take take rook takes King
b3 and I don't think I'm really in time
here to crate counter play just because
the b-pawn runs very quickly mm-hmm and
I rock King they're all well placed I
mean basically I'm down a piece right
King and Knight are working together and
I just had the two Brooks um so I I
decided to take on e5 which turns out to
be a blender the best move was rook c8
with idea forcing him to play rugby 4
and then playing f6 so I saw this line
it's a nice tactical point because if he
takes I have d5 and I win the piece but
um well he can get out of the pin take
on e5 95 counter play rook c3 exactly
and and here black block gets enough to
yeah he definitely gets enough play for
equality sure he's the king is now less
well placed and I felt like black is
probably okay here but in the game I was
just playing for more mm-hmm roley's
more more Clara counterplay but
objectively this was the way to go
because after rook takes e5 I was
expecting king b3 and my idea here is
simply to bother the night I don't
really care about the FI pawn right now
but I challenge the night I want to play
rook III check rookie - I would love to
play rook a3 check and force his king in
front of the a pawn because then he's
just from the way I'll have work a7
check and all kinds of counter play yes
but then he shocked me so it's white to
play if you guys want a nice puzzle try
to find the strongest move that gives
you very clear winning in game advantage
I don't know if you saw earlier from the
I have not cheated okay
I mean the first thing that comes to
mind is ripped 87 yeah yeah that's
forcing moves did you miss that
yeah completely just forgot about this
idea that his knight is pinned so
deflection deflection because in my mind
I don't care about the d7 pawn right I
just want to activate my Rex I'll give
all my funds if I can go after you lose
it then you care but well what I
realized that he he simplified the
position now normally when you're
playing in exchange down you don't want
to trade off your rook because you you
need this rook it's a long-range piece
you can combine to create threats and
it's in single piece end games like rook
versus night where the rook is showing
the dominance but he's also getting rid
of my counter play by taking off one of
my rooks so now my one rook can do very
little in a position if I take on d7 he
can just take on e5 of course and now
his knight is ready to come back to c4
to c6 he pushes b5 as pawns are just
gonna be unstoppable my king his way too
far I mean
usually this just looks lost for black
yeah oh it's interesting how tricky it
is to actually win this for whites well
I think this position is is almost
resigned all because he's gaining time
in the game I chose rook c8 here which
is accurate because okay he's gonna play
with the eight same idea but he doesn't
get this tempo mm-hmm
and maybe it's not such a big deal but I
like that my work is a little bit
farther
sure okay so I definitely realized I'm
losing here and I'm just trying to
create a counter play I think it's a
miracle that I saved the game to be
frank but I think it's a good maybe a
good lesson for kind of practical
defense and also conversion converting
the advantage from my point of view I'm
just trying to make it as hard as
possible the conventional wisdom is to
try and use the King to blocking his
pawns and then at the right moment
activate the rook and give checks from
behind yeah if I can take one of his
pawns on the Kings side then I can
create counter play and this would be
very important and there might be even
positions where if by some miracle I'm
able to give my rook for both of his
pawns and on the Kings side I have an
extra pawn or two extra pawns I have
some drawing chances by trading off all
the pawns
so these are the miracles that you know
you kind of hope for okay a four I
played into Keaney 794 so now King d7 96
check it's a big problem so started
rookie eight he pushes King d8 I'm just
trying to stay out of range of his
Knight and okay here he started spending
some time because he realized my rook is
coming to e2 so I'm getting counter play
needs to be precise of course we're both
in pretty heavy time trouble at this
point it's probably five minutes per
side thirty second increment and what's
interesting here is that you know white
is winning simply by force how do you
just push the pawns
he played King before which is I think a
very solid move but how do you just push
the pawns
concretely I'm not in time so I can try
rookie to b6 let's
a king c8 seems most logical just
getting the king over a six can be eight
and nine a five and this is a typical
construction be seven ninety six ninety
six p7 yeah everything everything with
check that's rough he also has the plan
to put the plumber in a seven and then
try to bring the knight to c7 sure which
is gonna be similarly winning and
because my rook is on the second rank
this is especially bad because I can't
get behind so in some cases his King is
actually very nice on b3 um instead what
followed was a lot of mistakes this
would be fairly classified as a
tragicomedy okay he plays instead of a
five you plays king b4 which probably
just wasting time I mean it's still
winning but it's not the most
straightforward rookie - and now g4 now
during the game I actually thought this
was a good move because well I thought
okay if he just pushes there are lines
where let's say black just takes both
pawns the problem is you calculate lines
like this for example and then this can
very easily go wrong for white if the
pawns get stuck so for example you might
think Oh Knight a5 check King e8 but
then what like ninety six there's still
no threat and your rook is coming back
your H bones gonna advance exactly in
here I'm ready to give my work at any
moment right even if I leave them with
one pawn that just can't be promoted so
quickly and then run with my H pawn and
Knights are notoriously bad at dealing
with the h1 so it's understandable why
you wouldn't want to go for a line
having not calculated it through and my
partner that means a very strong player
is very concrete calculating a lot so he
doesn't want to just go for it thinking
I'll probably be winning now in reality
it is winning you if white is precise I
think pushing the a pawn first makes
sense because if I just take on
each to its immediately losing a seven
rookie to in blocks so game over
I'm forced to play a king c8 then you
can push only move here would be rg1 if
I take the pawn at this point I think in
95 is winning next move is a 7 otherwise
can be 896 check and that would have
been game over
nice little mate um well okay so it's
understandable why he played g4 because
he didn't want to give us counter play
now it's harder for me to make a pass
pawn I keep trying
g6 a5 take take take and a6 and here
it's a mistake because after rook a to
his pawns are stuck
if net a5 we draw by force kind of a
nice endgame here you can see it or king
c7 a7 I can take king b7 it's actually
one of us to figure out how to draw this
because this King is nothing the square
of a pawn but of course there's the
famous ready idea maybe would have been
a good puzzle huh no but if you guys
want to try and figure it out just gave
you a very big hint but I feel like I
mean possible elimination
what can you even try here wait can come
might go free
ok so I see the the drawing idea button
can let go for b6 is it just too slow
I'm sure I'd bring the King to me the
King on g6 right
h4 can see 5 h 3 g6 it's just I wanted
to play a DH and then King see suddenly
yeah green just in time
well yeah but just by one tempo yeah
right but if the King was one square
closer mm-hm
you would have this position you'd be
winning great yeah so here is on the
white to move and draw yeah wait to move
and draw
a king upon in game two connected
pastors okay you guys one more time you
can pause the video do you have to
jettison the pawn and for anyone who
hasn't seen this idea before I mean it
is pretty remarkable the point is to
combine threats now by going through b6
if the King gets to c7 he's a lot faster
so h5 would be a colossal blunder white
plays king c7 and just Queens
immediately with check so black is
forced to play King b8 and because of
this one tempo white is now in time to
get in the square of the pawn and this
is going to be what's going on here
kin might still turn room no just
concretely black gets it back in time
uh-huh actually there's one more idea
white should kind of note into all this
derision yeah because if he goes forward
it's risky
yes but in this case you can basically
just give the pawn as long as you're
taking the opposition when black takes
it first don't forget this one there
have been a lot of situations where
white resigns in this position thinking
they're losing the pawn and the wore
white just plays King at 4 and gets
black that tragic exactly
so a6 was a blunder it blows the wind
mm-hmm of course I gave him more chances
out of this okay b6 was better because
now after rook a - he can play king b5
and his pawns are not stuck mm-hmm and
so here he's he's winning simply he's
gonna Queen first maybe Knight a5 or um
that's even I think b7 King c7
95 threatening Ono thärning a 17 season
but the running knight c6 and then be a
queen maybe there's a better way maybe
just 95 first is stronger and what is
always Queenie with check so h6 rook a
to he plays king c5 which is the the
best attempts King c8 the King c7 was
better
96 check King V 8 takes on f7 h5 at this
point there's like a big crowd around
the game cuz it's just a little
confusing with everyone what's going on
like as a past plot like there's three
passed pawns yeah I wasn't sure what was
going on here
I didn't know who was playing for a win
here I think I mean we both thought that
you know it's white who's the stronger
side here and and still definitely is
all objectively would best play black I
think is holding this yeah it is risky
for way because if the hp1 runs down the
board and I give my rook at the right
time for his past pawn then he can lose
but he he finds the best way he plays um
here he plays King b6 actually think 95
was maybe better but King b6h 495 and at
first I thought wait a minute I have
rubbed g2 here his night is so far away
you know why can't I just leave my king
but then of course a seven-night he said
yeah but I realized Oh his night is
actually in perfect range in the 97
check and me or if I let's say plan to
give the rook his King gets that perfect
spot in this 6b7 b6 b7 exactly
everything with Jack
so yeah route g2 is a great way to lose
the game if you guys want to pause the
video there's exactly one move that
draws for black it's a very it's not a
hard move to find actually I think is
just a hard move to let's say
convince yourself to play because it's
basically the last move you'd want to
play in the position any guesses I'm not
cheating but I think I know it just eats
three Hey
I mean concretely this is the only way
to draw because you displace the night
for enough time the point is that okay
he has to take the pawn I think some of
that rugby - I was singing her gage -
and then when the five fun more forcing
me
I think we're gage - he just comes back
to e6 I mean it's not working
yeah cuz he's uh because he's running
everything with check yeah exactly
I'm not sure why the engine gave rook to
you - obviously I didn't see any of this
during the game they are rolling on the
plate rook rook check check and then at
six
and so his king is not well placed and
so this position is drawn this was gonna
draw like minor piece plus two passports
is it theoretical draw against the rook
it looks good but you always have
chances to give the rook for both of the
pawns
you also have ideas are giving the rook
for a piece and one of the pawns and
then the resulting King and pawn and
game is drawn um here White's issue is
that the nightís pin and so he just
can't maneuver something like b6 and
it's always important just keep it as
far away as possible
now if King c6 I can always give checks
and then come back and white just can't
make progress here amazingly it's a draw
did you know that during the game yeah I
thought if we could liquidate I should
be fine I think I've just had the
endgame before and kind of learned that
way but the thing is this with pawns on
the Kings side you don't always get the
side of the pump the checks from the
side so it's some much more dangerous
okay anyway I played rugby to here which
is losing but my deal was to try this
rookie six check he puts my King on
eight plays ninety-six
I'm forced to play rugby six and then
this is where he really starts missing
the wins so King c7 I thought was was
very clear here now first things first
I'm not in time to just run with my HP
because he takes and I will get to Queen
yeah
he'll queen with a skewer it's like the
final scene of searching for bobby
fisher' I was just thinking that yeah
what a sad sad and game dr. King seesaw
and I'm forced to move my rook then he
plays b6 threatening b7 I'd have to play
rugby one and then f6 and so the second
pawn is too much and white white Queens
first and with me but he didn't want to
play King c7 because he's still hoping
to get b6 and night c7 and so he plays
king c5 rugby one apparently rig d7 was
a defensive move Rick Devon allows him
to repeat the position with King be sexy
but he can also actually in the game
after b6 King be seven how do you play
it f6 here white is still winning and
we'll see why once we go through the
game in the game he plays 97 which looks
very good it looks like it but black has
this resource which is actually more
common than then people might imagine
but of course I give the rook
now the knight is in the worst Square
possible and it's very important not to
use this tempo taking the night after
the game he confessed he he missed this
idea of course we're in time trouble so
you know understandable and what we got
in the game is black is actually
queening first white is also queening
but this resulting position White's
pieces could not be worse placed they're
just all sidelines
yeah the King has no shelter exactly and
so yeah just everything is going for
black here I mean number one he has
limited squares cuz he can't run into
the skewer he has no way of blocking the
check and if we trade Queens at any
point and I can take the knight and it's
gonna be a drawn endgame unless his King
is on d6 ready to come to c6 not c7 but
c6 can be 8 B 7 so this is essentially a
pretty easy draw for example you might
try here
check-check
and nothing to do I can trade Queens I
can even take a night in this position
it's an easy draw so that was it
basically queen c1 check I gave this
cheque and we agreed to a draw I was
hoping you know that's hoping for
I was hoping for King a5 and I what were
you gonna play here I assume there's a
stalemate would be five anyway that's a
nice one yeah I actually didn't see it
during the game I just noticed that no
yeah uh-huh
um because I was just how's it be
looking for these still mates but no I
would just repeat and of course yeah so
going back to the the final key position
how do you not play ninety seven here
had he started with f6 now he's one
tempo ahead cuz I can play h3 f7 I have
to put my right behind in here you can
play ninety-seven it seems so simple
what do you say you missed that you
didn't have to take the Knights I just
page three yeah I mean it's so easy to
just assume just as it is gonna be
played right especially in your
calculation when you're in time trouble
and just trying to calculate very
quickly you know just making these
forcing those automatically but of
course in these kinds of end games you
know anyone has seen in-game studies
there are all kinds of insane resources
that you have to watch out for so yeah
very very fortunate save yeah good job
what can I say we thought we were both
keeping clean so far who do you play
tomorrow so tomorrow I'm playing I think
another candidate master around 2200
that's doing well in the tournament so
should be should be a tough fight and
I'm playing a GM so we we can't have
like a clean name for the video anymore
we've stopped playing the same types of
players right and we stopped
well I haven't stopped
I don't know we're gonna call this video
he's got analysis round five I don't
know something about you yeah yeah we'll
brainstorm all right anyway let's see
you guys in the future probably bye